I met so many families moms and dads
brothers and sisters all adjusting to a
new normal when a child tells them I'm
not a boy or I'm not a girl but as the
same goes it takes a village so I
wondered how are the institutions who
helped raise our children adapting to
this gender revolution grammar schools
daycare and that right of passage
summer camp so I traveled to Long Island
to meet Sadie a tiny camper on the front
line
she's on a gender journey of her own and
the entire community here at Hampton
Country day camp is along for the ride
let me show me around John okay low
robes whoa-ho-ho this is like a zipline
right yeah that's so cool
so Sadie is the first transgender camper
here at Hampton Country Day camp yes I
could say it's been a big adjustment
were you worried about her making this
transition because she started here as a
boy while it initially took me by
surprise I think through conversations
and just kind of looking at it in a
rational way and trying to figure out
how this was going to work out on and
knowing
Sadie as proposed wonderful little child
to just such a happy child this is camp
camp is about being happy
so our concerns were really how Sadie
was going to make the transition here
and how other campers were going to
receive her so there were a number of
things to consider
it was never a question of would we do
this it was just a matter of how will we
do that never a question never question
so how old were you Sadie when you said
when you thought to yourself and you
started telling your mom and dad I'm not
a boy I'm a girl I think as well when
you heard from Sadie's parents that she
was going to be coming to camp as a girl
at six
were you surprised I wasn't because I
had been speaking to her mother even at
the age of three I think a lot of people
listening to this conversation might
think
that's just too young how do you know at
such a young age that this is who you
are and could it just be a faith I think
that's probably the question what people
ask I just use the facts that have been
given to me and that is children
actually formulate a gender identity at
a very young age and it can be as young
as two or three that they'd begin to
demonstrate this is exactly what we saw
in Sadie when she was here at camp and
you have to allow them to express
themselves freely and be the people that
they are the seminars that we've
attended and we go to camp conferences
there had already been a lot of
discussion going on sleep awake hamster
now starting to consider these
situations and started to educate
ourselves a little bit about this
because we knew that you know we're on
the horizon of change and tell me about
other campers and their parents was that
tricky I called every person who had a
child that was going to be in Sadie's
group to come except giving them the
information about what we were planning
to do so what was the reaction was there
any resistance from family it was
amazing they were so welcoming to the
idea I was actually surprised by how
easy it was Sadie was in a boy's group
at page five and then a girl's group at
Sadie's at age seven how did the campers
react the campers were just welcoming to
her there was certainly steps that we
took to make sure that her privacy was
respected and and the privacy of the
other campers was respected so her
changing was handled separately and you
asked Sadie's parents you need to have a
bathing suit that affords her more
modesty than maybe other girls
exactly I know you went shopping for a
bathing suit this year for a girls baby
too right was that exciting for you
mm-hmm yeah tell me about your bathing
suit pink I liked it I was like that was
best shopping in my life and when Sadie
changes she goes to a private area you
go through step for it area to change is
taken by a counselor which
Sehun and go to a separate bathroom and
enter changes in that back in a very
short amount of time it seems that our
perception of gender has changed
dramatically there's so much going on
around the issue and people can just be
accepting of who people are and give
them an opportunity to express
themselves his joyous I mean this is a
joyous child how could we ever take that
away from her makes her feel painful for
who she is
just doesn't seem right or fat
[Music]
mmm
Oh